I also think that you discard the wisdom
of the past so Talib uses that example
of the absence of evidence isn't
evidence of absence and not only do you
discard the wisdom of the past you also
discard and probably even more
importantly the wisdom and the value of
the future let's say in 2009 somebody
was talking to you about cryptocurrency
it was just so against the consensus and
if you have such a close mind of where
there's been studies so far or where
Goldman Sachs are putting their money
you're just always gonna get average
results because you're following the
crowd what you rarely ever get to see
like specific knowledge like the
intricacies of like frontiers and nuance
and that's why I love hanging around
with curious people because will tell
you like the weirdest new thing that's
happening
George McGill's long-awaited return to
modern wisdom how are you brother I'm
good I'm good how are you very very well
the crowd has been anticipating this one
for a long time you feeling ready yeah
as ready as you can be I guess this guy
yeah so my first question you are
currently the title holder of modern
wisdoms most ever played episode so just
looking at the best played your first
then dr. Eric feigl ding explaining
about a global pandemic two episodes
with Morgan Housel who used to write for
The Motley Fool Ben Greenfield Brian
Mackenzie then another episode with you
Derek Siver's John Assaraf and Aubrey
Marcus so that that comes out the top
ten why do you think our episode our
first one specifically and then the
second one why do you think that
resonated so hard Farms operation
involving about ten to twenty thousand
pounds vpns different IP addresses
because you need it all to come from
individual phones as well but it was
well worth yeah yeah yeah because we
also made our episode was the fourth
best podcast of 2019 as voted by podcast
notes audience so the bot farm also
useful for that as well yeah yeah they
do they do all sorts I'm trying to now
diverse into politics as well okay so
let's say that someone hasn't listened
to our first two episodes which they
should totally go back and check out and
let's say that they haven't what is a
mental model give us the Twitter bio
description of mental models I guess the
way I view it is my metaphors analogies
or just ways of taking principles from
different disciplines and then almost
trying to keep them in your own mental
toolkit that you can that you can apply
I just find it up a fun way of trying to
put together
a world with trillions of different
inputs I get it yeah I think the the
analogy used on the first episode was if
you think of your brain as the operating
system mental models are the different
apps that you can install to give you
functionality and to improve your
decision-making and that's now although
it's copyrighted judge McGill 2019 I've
been using that as like my my one-liner
too so let's get started what have you
been thinking about recently what you
drop in on us today
yeah I'm just just thinking I've got a
few things here so the one what I was
trying to think what we haven't been
through as well so try and keep things a
bit fresh yes otherwise it's just a
repeat right a repeat after a replay so
the one that I'd be thinking about a lot
just in general because it be could it
come so come so difficult to me as a
person and maybe it was like a certain
generation I was brought up upon
I would like leverage and what that
actually means like the ability the way
I view leverage is similar to way I
think this Peter Thiel talked about
technology which is the ability to do
more with less and that for me of a
generation who was brought up on YouTube
videos talking about 16 hour work days
and like hostile hustle hustle hustle
he's a very hard concept to sort of wrap
your head round and that when it
wouldn't start to begin to click for me
because I was always I was always one of
those people who want to like talk about
how hard they work and you realize a lot
that signaling it's just bollocks it's
not actually achieving a result was the
if might still be up there but there's
something called Steve Jobs is Lost
Tapes haveyouseenher
no it's fantastic so it's an interview
of Steve Jobs I think just before he
goes back to Apple for the second time I
mean like 1994 maybe and the interview
was lost for years they only found it in
like 2016 2015 about them and there's a
bit in it where I think he's used this
metaphor elsewhere as well but there's a
bit in it where he talks about reading
something when he was early on like a
study in scientific America where they
looked at the efficient
see of locomotion for all the animals
and the I think it was the Condor which
is a bird that one and the human being
which is the sort of and I know you like
to think of ourselves is probably the
best animal on the planet right look all
the [ __ ] we've done we was ranked like
Iran about the third way down the list
but what was interesting Steve says that
somebody other genius to like test that
human being on a bicycle and a human
being on a bicycle beat the Condor
absolutely destroyed every single animal
on there and you realized that that's
what human beings are we're just tool
makers right and that is so good so the
Condor what is Condor type of bird is
like a big legged bird bird yeah it's
like eating but no like like a flying
bunny birds okay yeah yeah yeah so
that's how leverage works by
implementing tools because it enhances
your ability your natural abilities are
then augmented and then big neva has
like four forms of leverage that always
stick with B so you have in terms of
like modern like more business side of
things you've got the traditional ones
which are like people leverage ie
Chris has a staff of 50 working for him
and therefore he can essentially put out
the strategy put out the systems put out
the products in place and then those 50
people provide a service or build things
for him therefore he's outputs therefore
then becomes even greater than his
inputs you have like financial leverage
which is like the buffett style of
things where you invest X and you get a
return of Y and you use your money as a
form of leverage for those are the two
old-school ones but the two new ones
which are fascinating though code-based
leverage which obviously powering like
Skype as we speak right now or any like
like you've got Shopify you've got
Amazon all these forms of leverage where
Jeff Bezos or Toby run Shopify aren't
working harder than us but they have
code they have machines or in my case
BOTS working 24/7 for them that works
way harder and then you've got the final
one which I guess is where you
specialize in is like media library
that rather than us just having this
conversation and only I was being able
to hear in it you have the ability now
to be able to distribute it on Macs -
lots of people without putting in any
extra work there's no extra cost of
replication for what you're doing so
there yeah those are the four forms of
leverage and once you once you actually
look around and then any like business
you go in you got [ __ ] there's like
people leverage there's media leverage
there's code leverage and you begin to
see it everywhere and it's fascinating
that's super cool yeah you totally
correct everybody knows this right I
guess there must be a network leverage
as well I don't know how that would fall
in but number one mmm someone's saying I
love the modern Western podcast that
host Chris is handsome and great and
then telling their friend my boss yeah
but one of your boss your boss says that
that is not me putting in the work to
source that new listener right the fact
that that episode that first episode
between us it's not add any paid ads
behind it but for some reason because of
the bots it's done so well and it's
gonna Dan that also to the people
listening
it might be worth playing a game of
either novel bingo or Buffett bingo
today and I'm looking good bingo yeah
and I'm clocking out I'm clocking up one
for Navarro and one for one for Buffett
so far so how can people perhaps use
leverage you know I'm not I'm not Jeff
Bezos people listening ain't Jeff Bezos
are there any ways that people can apply
leverage like just a small scale or in
an immediate sort of example in their
life
obviously it's okay specific to every
individual and I think sometimes an
issue with ideas like this is that
people try and like max distribute it to
everybody and it's it's so case
dependent but I just think like looking
at trying to reduce your inputs whilst
also maximizing your output so however
that may be right whether that's by a
media and you have a greater audience
that way or you hire people who you
trust that then obviously work for you
and then you can try and increase things
that way yeah I think it's so subject
specific but I think the two ones that
are only seen to be getting greater and
greater
Media leverage and code leverage but I
also think like bran leverage I was I
was watching an interview there drogon
and Elon Musk interview on the new one
the new one and I caught myself like
obviously I mean you can you you end up
on a Twitter game where you can find I
find it quite interesting where you find
people who obviously think he's the the
smartest man ever and then you have like
the trolls or maybe rational critics I
don't know who criticized various
different things but even I caught
myself like falling into the brand where
I'd listen to the interview and that you
anything I'd hear him say I was then
trying to rationalize into genius and
don't get me wrong a lot of it probably
is but that power of like a brand and
like he kiha ass Oprah House or even
like the most controversial example
where Trump has now where people use
these brands as a form of leverage and
it works for them and they can say
something that if somebody else said all
of us it can be interpreted as genius or
they get a second chance or they have
defenders for them just around a I can't
ban so to speak and I think brands is
another form of leverage that doesn't
get discussed enough cuz it's it's hard
to pinpoint it's hard to really explain
but we all like feel it it's the icing
on the cake which makes everyone presume
that it's going to taste good before
they even eat it I think that's one way
to look at it right that you you see
this cake and you're like oh my god not
only is this cake coming out of that
bakery that I've eaten that before and
everyone else eats at this bakery and
they all think it's mint and I've eaten
there before and I think it's min and
this cake looks so good it's got all the
trappings of the previous ones but
obviously as you've hit on there that
can become kind of a little bit of a
Trojan horse that delivers something
that's got less substance you hit it
with a hammer and you find out it's
hollow inside as opposed to filled with
delicious jam and cream filling which is
what we want um you've touched on two
things which linked into I haven't got
that many points this is a platform for
you to do your thing and to drop some
bombs but I got two things that link
into what you've come up with there so
I'm gonna I'm gonna go grab a couple of
bits we haven't done x zero yet have you
heard of that mental model yeah yeah
that's it's an interest it's like it's
not really a complex one it's a real
simple that everybody like year three
max I guess
it's that you can have 10 billion times
322 million add 52 billion but if you
then take that number and multiply it by
zero you end up with zero so I guess
it's kind of Talib's think about try and
avoid absolute ruin try and avoid yeah
that that multiplier by zero ie if you
get caught as an athlete doing steroids
the you've gone basically like yourself
talent yeah godless of whatever is going
on yeah identifies the weakest link in
the chain and no no system is stronger
than its weakest component right but the
same could be made for you have spent
all your life working on longevity
you've been intermittent fasting you've
not been eating processed foods you
don't drink alcohol you don't smoke you
don't do drugs but one day you decide to
drive without your seatbelt on you get
into a car crash like you're very dead
you know you were you doesn't matter how
healthy you are when you're very dead
and the same thing goes for you are
working real hard on your finances on
liberating yourself so that you have
freedom so that you can pursue the
things that you want so that you don't
have any financial burdens or any
responsibilities or whatever it might be
but upon one drunken night of
unprotected sex either you get pregnant
or you get somebody pregnant and then
there is a very big burden that you need
to pursue you know you go you gotta look
after that and it's like okay that's
multiplying by zero like doesn't matter
all the good stuff all the good stuff
you've done in the past
there is something now which is such a
large burden maybe there maybe it's not
multiplying by zero for the kid but it's
definitely putting a very hard stop you
know on a lot of the things that you
that you potentially had planned and the
point is that it wasn't something that
was planned
so yeah x zero is a really important one
I think for people to just look at
whether the weakest links in their chain
ah right like a lot of the time we see
this with productivity people say oh I
made I posted an image of alpha brain
the other day I don't take it that much
just a nootropic and I got tons and tons
of messages bro is this any good
like tell me like you know what what are
the sort of effects I might try and get
it and it's expensive as hell you've got
to pay an import charge from on it in
the US because they haven't sorted do
like their customs tracking thing either
but if I post something up about Cal
Newport deep work or doing Pomodoro's or
like a new productivity strategy no one
cares and it's like because that is the
weakest link in that chain and often
it's the one that shows kind of the most
the most discomfort is associated with
it
yeah there's it's similar a bit of a
model I've been thinking about the plate
as well which is like product versus
marketing and it's somebody who's a
marketeer or operates in the marketing
world you definitely I don't know Dean
can put it in or we can attach it to the
notes for the recent like Google Trends
of like the word best and the word cheap
and best he's going like that and cheap
overtime is just going like that
and I think that's a result of a Hugh a
huge focus on marketing and these like
hacks and without fixing the product
like the best I was used the best
example of like a fire festival for me
is one of the the most fascinating
business cases where as deceitful and I
could be wrong what will definitely
wrong what he did you cannot deny that
guy was a genius marketer and a genius
salesperson yeah and if you look at like
great combo so if you look at Steve Jobs
and Steve Wozniak you had jobs he want
seems a marketing genius then you had
was the app he was a product genius
obviously Jobs was a prodigy Gnaeus as
well but that combination of marketing
and product sees what made those guys so
strong and I find that if you have
Gerald as your business partner and not
so I always wonder if he had a Steve
Wozniak how different would that fire
festival have turned out if he had like
a key for a boy who can I execute and
focus on the operations and made that
party happen and maybe he would be a
billionaire right now maybe he would be
one of the best entrepreneurs my
generation but the fact that he had ja
Rule I always wonder like if Steve Jobs
had ja Rule how different would have
been so I do sometimes I like like the
the product and the market in because
you see it more and more like what's
fascinating if you wonder the holes I've
been down in quarantine is there Toby
lucky who's like the Shopify CEO I think
he's such a honest humble and like clear
thinker and what's fascinating is as
opposed sometimes I think wrongly by the
media Shopify and Amazon are where
Amazon are centralizing ecommerce and
Shopify decentralizing it and making it
about the merchants and people see what
key and Bezos is almost two opposing
figures which I don't think is true and
I think they both admit bad but if you
look at they're like shareholders
letters from like 2015 or even BAE's
loss like 1999
it's always about two things we don't
care about short-term revenues we don't
care about all this market and stuff all
we care about is long-term thinking and
customer satisfaction so even like
Shopify one thing in that growth
marketing that brands will do right but
if you was a growth marker and you came
in at Shopify early doors one of the
things you would have said to do is
always have powered by Shopify on the
store therefore like MailChimp do this
so therefore when somebody comes on the
store and sees it like oh oh this your
Shopify are the news it and as a result
Shopify would have a way bigger brand
because they basically tower like over a
hundred billion in e-commerce revenue
and there's so many people who don't
know what Shopify is who doesn't exist
in this but you know for a fact they've
bought from a Shopify store but Toby
purposely was so merchant focused
refused to have that powered by Shopify
there because he knew they're actually
providing the merchants with as much
value in the short-term would provide so
much more long-term value so you put the
product in that case before the
marketing and I think we're gonna see a
shift more and more towards that
Hadouken mark it's still super valuable
but when you are so mark in focus so
hack focus it only gets you so far and I
think that everybody cares more about
the product to the end of the day even
from just a non-financial viewpoint as
well there's more integrity associated
with actually fulfilling the thing that
you're saying that you're doing if your
company is there to enable the ecommerce
provider the ecommerce store at
maximize everything that they do like
put your money where your mouth is you
know like if you take your your
thumbnail watermark away and that makes
an impact that actually makes the store
look better then really if you're
sticking to your values and that is your
true values regardless of what it does
to revenue you should be doing it you
know and again in this world of
shareholder agreements and and early
annual reports and stuff like that that
is the it's gonna stand out not only
does it give you distinctiveness but it
genuinely should be more fulfilling to
you the only problem is when you've got
shareholders whose desire for the bottom
line outweighs that I guess you
mentioned before as well
fire festivals something I've been
thinking about so much since I watched
the documentary which is phenomenal is
how seduced we all are by success right
so that guy who's the guy that runner
what was his name again is it Billy
something Billy fart Billy McFarlane
that's it so Billy McFarland the only
reason that people slated him and that
he's a crook and that he's trying to
take advantage of people is because he
failed if he'd succeeded even if he
partially succeeded and it hadn't been a
total nightmare he would have been
hailed as marketing genius new Steve
Jobs this that any other there would
have been six people that said I think
this is a unfair way of doing marketing
I think that he's leveraging the lowest
common denominator of influencer
marketing and stuff like that but had he
have farted out a semi-successful
festival right people would have said oh
my God look at what this guy's achieved
look at how phenomenal the marketing was
like next year's gonna be insane because
we are so seduced by the end product its
success by any means right everybody
just cares about okay can is this person
the next hypetrain is this person the
next Steve Jobs is this person the next
whatever it might be and um yeah I
realized that the only reason that
people slated him was because the
festival failed really not because of
his methods
getting there mm-hmm okay I know I kind
of I kind of get what you mean but I
think that then just goes back to the
whole product and marketing thing that
if you have the best CBO Facebook
campaign where you have ten ad set
structured perfectly and you've used
dynamic creative testing to a/b test
everything and you're getting eight
rowers on a pair of jeans but the the
jeans turn up and there's a [ __ ] rip
through the crotch part people are going
to be mad at you and I think rightly so
right if you if you've advertised the
product that is and isn't good enough
but I think I think that's almost a good
thing you know I think that this focus
on the product is a super import and I
think it's they're going to be even a
greater and greater focus in the next 10
20 years
I would I would agree also there is a
model that I got introduced to by
Richard chaton who have you listened to
that episode yet I listened to the first
one I'm not listen to the second one
good because that means I can tell you
this for the first time well so in a
study there was a number of different
aphorisms that were given to people like
these sort of rules right and for
instance woes unite foes right that's
one of them but in another version of
the study they might have been told was
unite enemies and what that indicated
and this was run over a number of
different aphorisms a number of
different sentences what it indicated
was that people see rhyming sentences as
more believable than ones that don't
rhyme and when they were asked in
reflection so why was it de chose the
this is the most believable one or
whatever they didn't know one said like
he was because it rhymed and even a hat
they asked them they were like oh so was
it because it ran no no no no no it's
got nothing to do that it's just you
know I really feel like it connects with
me and whatever it might be but that
wasn't the truth when you control for
everything it wasn't the truth it's
because it rhymed what that tells us is
that mental fluency is associated with
truthfulness
and that has such huge implications
right you know Grant Cardone is someone
who's unbelievably fluent the way he's
able to deliver things with power and
with conviction and all this sort of
stuff and yet there's entire websites
dedicated to calling him out for some of
the stuff that he does that's not to
make it a value column whatever it
whether it's true or false were how he
operates his business but you can't deny
the fact that that is someone who is
using mental fluency to augment their
truthfulness right and I think that that
kind of links into what you're saying
there with this kind of marketing first
approach which again hit it with a
hammer you find there's nothing inside
it's it's dangerous yeah I agree it
tastes once like a model I've been
thinking about a blade which I kind of
call like the linguistic matrix or like
a linguistic red pill and I realize that
Haunter your reality is just shaped by
the words that you have available and
the ability to then put like
placeholders on things so even like a
word that like shortened Freud for
example it's a word that's I think it's
German it's a very English thing of
taking pleasure in somebody else's
failure all pain the ability to actually
have that chunked into a word ability
give a completely gives you an ability
to understand reality slightly
differently but I think if you look
right now like one thing I absolutely
hate because it's just a team sport is
that most modern politics and if you
realize if you look at most these like
280 character debates on Twitter where
there's just all caps and swear words
and clapping calling anybody with fists
at the end or yeah it's just these both
both teams are exactly the same and one
of the things that is often an issue is
that there's a whole if you can imagine
we've got this whole like Jenga tower
that this is based on and their sword
fighting at the top of this Jenga tower
but they still never ever define the
fundamental words that they're using so
like sometimes they'll be debating about
a specific word without actually
defining it like even like to like what
examples I have the
a political but let's say the word like
ego for example is an interesting one
use it for so many different meanings
that then to icon then sometimes try and
understand something but it's within the
word ego I've got five different
meanings and I think it completely
distorts my my view of reality so that
people will use ego for example in the
Kanye West's sense of like thinking that
I am the [ __ ] man and like nobody can
stop me that style or like the Michael
Jordan on the court style of ego and
then like the more like Buddhists
Eckhart Tolle perspective of ego is the
sense of self this sense that you're an
individual and you're not completely
just an organism connected to all the
billions of organisms out there and I
find that we actually should define the
the individual instances within that to
even have a clearer understanding of
reality like one one of them that is
fascinating as well is the word
entrepreneur because within the word
entrepreneur there's so many different
kinds of entrepreneurs my favorite
example is Joe Rogan I talk about media
leverage he has maybe what four or five
members of staff like him Jamie and I'm
sure he's got a few of the people behind
the scenes does like 100 plus Miller
ever knew from his podcast alone you
know he doesn't even have a personal
assistant no no he said it on a podcast
the other day says he refuses to have a
personal assistant he's like [ __ ] that
what do I need someone to just tell me
when the tip with the train ticket to
book four tell me when my flight leaves
it's like I'll book the flight myself
[ __ ] so funny I was probably why
he's quite well connected to everything
that's going on as well I think that's
probably actually an advanced advantage
to him but he yeah he has insane media
leverage but one of the things that you
wouldn't be able to say about Joe is
that he's like an entrepreneur because
that when you soon as you think of
entrepreneur you think of like okay I'll
give him 10 grand and flip it into 20
grand and you'll do all these salesmen
that's not roving in the slightest like
he's not a CEO he's not that kind of guy
but he has a business worth over a
hundred million dollars that employs a
few members of staff with what like
ninety nine percent there's an issue
with that we need to then define the
words within the words because we end up
just keep shrinking chunk in forever and
up on me
that's one of the reasons why I love
Eric Weinstein for example because he
just
great words all the time and I find that
you go through your whole life with like
these words that have been given to you
rather than trying to actually create
your own vocabulary based off what
you're seeing in reality you're always
trying to outsource people to make words
for you it's really weird I think this
probably strikes at why so many people
talk past each other online and you
think you've got differing points of
view you have two people that inherently
want to disagree so we're already
looking for that disagreement perhaps
then they're all excited and anxious and
stuff for being online and typing away
smash in the keyboard and then even the
terms that they are using that they are
debating aren't agreed on inside bro
you're never you might as well be
speaking different language you know
you're never gonna make that work and
this I keep bringing this up I'm gonna
do again if you have not read 1984 you
have to go and read it especially if you
like the idea of what George is talking
about here I learned more from 1984
about the way that I operate then I have
done from a lot of personal development
self development books right and the
thing that it taught me was that the
ability to articulate words the ability
to put your thoughts into a noise that
comes out of your mouth or into words
that go down on paper is directly
proportional to the quality of your
thoughts like if you can't say it it
never takes form and if it never takes
form it's no longer an actual concept
it's just a notion you know it's like
the smell of the thing that you think
and you're like oh that's interesting
it's kind of a bit like that so roll
that forward the implication is if you
want better thoughts
you need a bigger vocabulary the more
words that you have at your disposal
genuinely the better your the quality of
your thoughts is going to be and this is
why I've got such a love for language
right and adore fight picking of
bloviate I discovered the other day
which I absolutely adore which is kind
of like someone that befores and talks a
lot about talks a lot about stuff
without actually really saying anything
right analogous to a ton of different
words but blow via has like that's cool
I now have a word that I can use for
when someone is below the
but until I have that word it's just a
sense or it's me having to use another
word which is analogous to that it's a
proxy for that right and yeah not only
does it does it make life richer but it
genuinely improves the quality of your
thoughts some 100% on board with that
yeah it's almost like rather than having
all these like detailed lines of code
somebody's just put it into one function
and then you can just execute like it's
a much smooth and that if you look at
the way I'm not the guide talk about
software systems but if you look at the
way that we're they're making it easier
and easier and the chunking and chunking
people's previous work so yeah it makes
sense that to be able to actually have a
specific word as opposed to like a
fluffy concept and then words within
those words is a much precise and clear
a way of operating like one of the wings
I was thinking about this is a bit a bit
Willy but I the word time is itself
quite deceptive and a bit of a proxy I
think I'm gonna see a lot of people in a
weird situation right now where they
reflect on how they spend their time day
to day and you'll talk about how I work
full time or I do XYZ but time is like
like that's what it is at the end of the
day this is a proxy for the word life
and when you actually don't like think
about so you're doing a full-time job
that you hate it's actually a full life
job that you hate you know and I mean
like it's it's your life but I think
time is itself like this weird proxy for
the word light and we almost it's almost
a lot more existentialist if you have to
use the word life and I think it's
actually quite a useful tool to change
those two words always time use like
this this thing that you have like money
and it's not it's it's just this it's
all you've got and it's slowly pouring
away and it may end at any second I
guess the most depressing as that sounds
a man if people don't want to be
depressed they should listen to a
different podcast um it's the one
resource that you can't not spend as
well right like you can save money you
can save calories can choose not to buy
that coffee you can choose not to eat
that cake you can't choose to not exist
for the next hour it's like that time is
gonna be spent so you just better choose
that you spend it as well as you can
what do we got next what's up next so
one of the ones I've been thinking about
because of everything that's going on
about imagine a lot of people have
experienced there is like forcing
functions so something it's almost a lot
of people talk about the wonders of
freedom and the beauties of Liberty and
I completely agree and love freedom and
love Liberty but sometimes without
something like I'm a BDSM come some
beauty to having restricted freedom in
the sense that I always use the example
I know some lazy pockets like some
really lazy people including myself at
times but if they have to be at a job
for 9:00 a.m. they will get up on time
and they will attend but as soon as
that's taken away they'll begin up at
1:00 p.m. they're getting up at 2:00
p.m. and the only thing was changes of
like a forcing function of what Daniel
brush is an example with two examples
one with like a YC demo day like the
ability he says that a lot of Y
Combinator's success not success but the
reason one of the beauties behind going
through YC is that you have a deadline
at the end of it and as a result the
work just fits to that deadline if that
deadline didn't exist it maybe takes two
years maybe takes three years that's
like a hard forcing function and he also
says like one of the reasons why a lot
of amazing technology particularly in a
defense space comes out Israel it's
because they have to write like you know
I mean I in the in the UK but there's no
the u.s. there's not there's not as much
attack on your like land or I'm gonna
say yeah no imminent danger shall we say
so that's one of reasons why I like
Israel has such a forcing function but
Israel doesn't produce snapchats of the
world isn't really produced Twitter's of
the world as a result because they don't
have awareness when you have that more
relaxed freedom they tend to produce
that but when you have a forcing
function it can produce some amazing
things like Peters here was he like even
now like the amount of companies who
would never have in a million years let
their employees work from home I've now
been forced to do it and they're going
actually we don't need an office anymore
we're gonna go full remote like it's
crazy as a result of this like forcing
function that is a pan
I guess yeah shout-out to Chris sparks
forcing function calm his he's a big
lover of that so how do you actually
define what a forcing function is I
think it I think it comes from the
actual model itself probably comes a
program England it's something that you
just can you can't get past without
doing a certain thing but then the way
you obviously chunk that forever areas
is almost you're forced to do a certain
thing basically all all the pain of not
doing it is way greater than the pain of
of putting it up it's not even right the
pain of not know the pain of not doing
it is way greater than the pain of of
doing it so I think that's how I
describe it or the pleasure of doing it
is way greater than the pleasure of not
doing it so just real simple pleasure
and pain incentives which is a lover
model I guess one of the things that
I've been thinking about to do with that
kind of forcing function and how it ties
in is just Parkinson's Law I can't
remember whether we brought this up last
time and I don't even know if it classes
as a mental model but we're free-flowing
today we can do what we want Parkinson's
Law work expands to fill the time given
for it so it's the same reason that you
don't do your university assignment
until the night before it's the same
reason that the project that you need in
for work requires an all-night it to be
pulled and I think using a forcing
function like that when you think about
the YC days and things it actually
requires you to focus on what them the
Minimum Viable Product is as well like
if you know that you've only got six
weeks to complete this particular
project for YC you're not going to
bother
gesticulate ng for two weeks on whether
the brand logo should be mostly red or
mostly yellow like it's going to force
you to focus on the things that move the
needle and when those degrees of freedom
get expanded out as you've identified
right now there's no boss telling you
why you not awake at 9:00 a.m. what do
you call it earlier honor a furloughed
preneur
[Music]
the absolute best you know when you
don't have that you don't have anybody
who is the disciplinarian who's who's
telling you to do these things you
realize oh hang on actually or the only
reason I was overcoming my own inertia
was because of this structure this
buttress this scaffolding that was
layered around my life and I think that
those increased degrees of freedom are
causing people a lot of and rightly saw
they're causing people a lot of
discomfort as I've said on a number of
different podcasts I was taking a lot of
pleasure in the beginning until I sort
of checked myself and said stop being a
dick I was taking a lot of pleasure with
other people's struggling to
self-discipline
I was watching people suffer with the
same challenge that I faced as a self
independent entrepreneur for the last 13
years hours are so hard working from
home isn't it can't imagine what that's
like
and then I checked myself and I was like
hang on a [ __ ] second mate like you
need to let's be a little bit more
empathetic here like you shouldn't be
taking pleasure at the fact that other
people have stepped into your nightmare
you know like so but it's it's right
increased degrees of freedom for your
forcing functions yeah it's I just think
one of the things I always find actually
like great content is whenever you hear
somebody say I when they when they turn
30 or only to them 40 when they turn 50
units even like a letter to their 20
year old self you're all set set arow
one of the consistent theme seems to be
like putting that proper things off or
putting the things off that they should
have done and I think that for myself
and I probably don't do enough but I
think in general a lot of the consistent
themes when people talk about those
regrets is that there wasn't enough
force in functions in place to actually
get them to do it it was always this
pipe dream in the future and I think
that if we had more sometimes restricted
freedom in certain areas that we we
purposely do ourselves whether that's
putting up like a just giving fun
because you're gonna run a marathon or
whatever it is it actually works even
though you whilst you're doing it you
kind of hate yourself for actually
putting yourself through it but if he
earns were always like Bangkok I did
that I think it's it's a it's a
beautiful concept even
feels horrific at the time really a
really really clever way of putting it
together man yeah I mean that everyone
that's listening has has decided to
obsess over the things that don't matter
because it's a form of procrastination
on getting on to the stuff that actually
does and you know for me with this
podcast like I've I'm I still feel like
I got it out early like you know the
start of 2018 by no one's estimations is
early but by now like when you look at
how many people are now bringing them
out and how much more the podcast
network is growing and stuff like that
it feels early right but at the time I'd
already messed around for six months I'd
spent six months I'd gone through tons
of different brands I'd played with
different and then I came up with modern
wisdom like it's 3:00 a.m. woke up and
was like had this name I was like yes
finally got the name right now onto the
logo me like bro it doesn't matter
people want to tune in because of what
you say because of the content that you
put out and in reflection now I can say
pulling the pin on that and just
deciding to do it and messing up with
the audio I'm messing up with the video
and not having in support and not doing
this correctly and doing all these
problems right you're like over time
right now I'm so glad that passed me did
that because present me is reaping all
of the rewards and you just iterate over
time what we got next what else you got
on the on the menu my one of my favorite
ones at the minute and I love it when
you have because the thing about the
models as well is that is sometimes just
a bit fluffy and so you have like
real-world examples that you can rest it
on so global versus local maximum I'm
again as I mentioned going down a bit of
a Tobias looking whole the Shopify CEO
and he uses a great example to explain
the global versus local maximum which
I'll come on to but it's basically local
maximum local Maxima is operating so
let's say for example it would be
focusing on optimizing one specific
variable so that maybe be the focus on
getting the best exhaust possible for
your car constantly trying to optimize
1% games for the exhaust when you
realize you're not gonna [ __ ]
steering-wheel so
you've gotta you've gotta sometimes
whereas that'sthat's what the global
maximum is of like looking like almost
from an absolute objective perspective
at the whole thing and then optimizing
for that so one of the entrepreneurs
that doesn't get anywhere near enough
attention because it's not sexy and you
realize this like everybody knows who
Mark Zuckerberg is but nobody knows who
the CEO of like Citibank is or Goldman
right because it's it's way more b2b
it's not b2c but Malcolm McLean you know
Malcolm McLean is know so basically he
was the is that he was the guy that
basically came up with the idea of
shipping containers he was a combat come
on it and this is what often global
maximum will come from at the time
everybody was focused on getting faster
and faster ships so we could basically
create globalization as we know it now
where you can get bananas from the other
side of the world in January and they
were getting faster and faster ships and
he was as a truck driver was one day on
I think it was Thanksgiving was sat
there in nine hours with cargo on his
back waiting for people to get each
individual box off and then back when he
says why don't we just chunk it all
together and you just take that off as a
container and you can just place it on
the ship and then you literally take and
then once the ship arrives you can just
take the one container stick it onto a
train or rail and ship it that way and
everybody basically laughed at him and
footage of ridiculous idea because they
were optimized on getting each
individual box up at the time and for
some context of like how how good this
idea was at the time it was $6 a ton
doing the previous method where and they
was focused on the local maximun of
trying to make the the ships go faster
when he implemented what he did it went
down to 16 cents a ton so like it goes
to show that and also instead of like a
week for them to load a ship it was then
eight hours for them to load of shipment
so you think about him as an individual
on the global maximum perspective like
me impacts that have has on the world is
insane by every trade everything imagine
the fact is not a Dane
in doctoring goes to show that if you're
not b2c it's not sexy you're rich and
anonymous but like something that is a
perfect example now I think I think he's
dead now because this is like I think he
could yeah this is like the 50s when it
began to come in place I think he's dead
now
but the Shopify CEO he has a great
example where he Toby says that when he
gets asked in the interview thinks on
the knowledge project where he says my
whole goal as a as the CEO is to assume
right now that where we're at in modern
day business I'm at six maybe the best
company in the world is like a six to
keep the goal is to get it to a seven
and that's my life's mission to get to a
seven so he's basically working on the
assumption that he's always wrong and
it's kind of true but if you look at
sport for example if you look at
football or soccer or whatever you want
to call it like the gap between the
modern athletes and 40 years ago he's
just huge and you but we we weirdly have
this thing at the time where we assume
that this is the best thing possible
that the iPhone is like it's never going
to get better than this but it always
does and I think that the first thing to
do is assume that everything's wrong and
your goal is to be to be less wrong and
I think that then helps with potentially
getting a nearer to a global maximum if
that makes sense I love that concept man
that's the first time that I've heard of
it it's kind of like a rate limiting
step from chemistry as well right like
which also ties in to what we were
talking about before which is the
weakest x zero like you're only as
strong as your weakest link what did I
have in my head there I had one in my
head oh yeah can you do why it's
important why it better to avoid failure
than to face success or like why like
not being stupid is better than trying
to be clever
I can talk about it but I can't
necessarily do an actual and that's for
sure yeah I think yeah just I guess
looking at yeah things that are gonna
take you down it's someone I struggle
with but it goes back to that x zero and
I think I think the model that's
actually quite useful for identifying
that I've been playing since quarantine
been playing a ton of chess I'm still
[ __ ] but I've been playing a ton and
it's cool like lessons that come from
that one which is that your assumptions
will assumptions is everything and
there's always the right move that was
there the same over the shipping
container it wasn't like that idea
didn't exist it was just that people's
assumptions was that there was a better
way to do it they was focusing on the
the local maximum rather than the global
maximum
but there's a garry kasparov point which
guy Kaspar was one like the best chess
players of all time and I I think
sometimes people extrapolate chess to
life and there's loads of lessons you
can take which I do thinks partially
true but partially bollocks but there
are a few and one of the ones that
Kasparov has is the way used to analyze
his games so let's say for example he
made a mistake where he moved the Bishop
to e4
most people would come at it from
analyzing that move so they would go
okay I move Bishop to e4 and then I got
in a trap and I lost my bishop
therefore never do bishop to eat for and
instead what Kasparov the way he
analyzed his game and what he said was
so different about his approach was to
not just analyze the mood but analyze
the thinking behind the move like what
did I have for dinner that day what was
I thinking about at the time what
assumptions did I have in my head and
you have almost this system mindset
which is similar to systems versus goals
but looking at things in a much wider
system so like Safiye Bukhari talks
about this where and uses the example of
sin you come home and you argue with
your wife
accurate like a hard day's hard day's
work were for work about the dishes for
example like almost thinking about the
individual item or the pawn to the
bishop to e4 would be okay I'm never
going to bring up the dishes again but
instead
actually try and think about what what
was the thinking before all that
happened and you got oh actually good
cause of the mistake was me coming home
from work tired and angry and I took it
out on my wife and a good thing at the
genius thing about this is if you went
from the perspective of okay let's not
just use the let's never argue about the
dishes again and rather instead focus
about the let's not come home from work
angry or is that you prevent thousands
of similar mistakes from happening
rather than that just one again that's
an idea that is lovely in theory but
even harder to implement I'm not perfect
that's former more well it's much more
scalable right and we were talking about
this before we started where I was
saying about strategies versus character
and the fact that a lot of strategies
supplement for poor character traits you
know like a strategy of only ever having
three beers so that you never cheat on
your wife is a strategy to ensure that
you never cheat on your wife but the
trick d'etre of being faithful to your
wife is much more scalable you know
regardless of how much alcohol you have
now that's not to say that you should
still increase risk by having a bunch of
booze when you're in a strip club or
whatever it might be but the principle
is the same and I think it's kind of
like this malignant side effect of the
21st century and we contribute to this
I'm contributing to this and we're doing
it right now that we give people these
piecemeal solutions to what is a very
global problem it's like if you work on
your character if you work on your
values and your virtues what is it that
matters to you what is the reason that
you are here on this planet for like
genuinely as an existential terrible of
an existential crisis inducing question
as that is like what is the reason for
that because that those values those
virtues those non non compromisable
reasons for your existence are much more
scalable than having earth strategy
about like the best way I once read a
book about how's the best to bring kids
up therefore I'm gonna follow this
strategy it's like well yeah but where
do you think that strategy came from
that strategy
probably came from people who loved
their kids and did the things that were
right for their kids so there's again
like that marketing versus product thing
there is a combination between the
deployment of a strategy and what is the
essence of the reason that the strategy
exists and can you combine the two can
you deploy something which is effective
and also have something to to back it up
it's um yeah it's it's it's much easier
in theory and hard with practices that
quote I don't if it's Tyler but I know
it might be Yogi Bear and Talib uses it
of in theory there's no difference
between theory and practice but in
practice there is and I think this ties
me on to another thing I've been
thinking about of the this is a model
that comes from I'm a fan of him I even
I think he sex sometimes sometimes I
don't always like the content but I
think on the whole that thing he's
actually fantastic and was a lot of good
for the world which is Gary Vee and he
has a concept called dirt and clouds
which I think I actually like probably
his best video and his best piece of
content which is the way he thinks about
things is purely from a dirt and clouds
perspective so the way he defines that
for himself is the cloud is like the
high-end vision and the high-end
principles and the high-end character
stuff we're talking about so fame I
think is buying that the New York Jets
and providing like unreal value to the
world and his funeral I think Gary talks
about this he wants more people at his
funeral nearly of a funeral that's how
he defines every action by and then the
dirts for him is like the specific
tactical things of so for him it will be
knowing the tic-tock was a platform to
get on before anybody else and he was
investing a load of time on that or the
reason why pretty snapchat because he's
got hands-on
similar to the way Rogan doesn't have a
personal assistant that if you do have
like a PA or with Gary he outsources it
to everybody like the junior employees
he's no longer in the dirt he's no
longer relevant and he loses touch with
things but the dirt and the clouds so
like the high-end top level theory and
then the pure execution the pure action
and the basic says everything else in
the middle which is where you can so
easily spend your time he's just
absolute garbage and it's much easier
said than done Tom see only focus on the
dirt and the clouds but the politics the
the nonsense just spending time I'm
doing passive things that you don't even
enjoy is a it's just pointless put the
actual dirt and the clouds are the two
the two most important things throw back
to the first step
gray area thinking barbell strategy yeah
yet so you mentioned there you you
couldn't work out whether it was Talib
or whether it was Yogi Bear or whatever
it was and I mentioned to you on the
phone I was gonna I was gonna red pill
you on this Churchillian drift have you
heard of it yeah no okay wait
Churchillian drift is the term coined by
British right right and Nigel Rees which
describes the widespread misattribution
of quotes by obscure figures to more
famous figures usually of their time
period the term connotes the particular
agraria sness of misattributions to
British Prime Minister Winston Churchill
and this is just so funny they always
slides up right it's never like John
that has the ice cream van that came up
with this thing it's always like Tyler
Bourne eval or there go another one for
bingo it's always that and I find myself
doing it as well there's that quote that
keeps on being attributed to Aristotle
which is we are what we repeatedly do
excellence therefore is not an act but a
habit and that's supposedly Aristotle
but then if you actually dig into the
etymology of that particular quote you
find that there's quite a lot of
criticism and and sort of skepticism
around who came up with it and Richard
shot and told me I can't remember the
website I'll have to try and find it
that there's basically an equivalent of
like ancestry.com but for quotes and you
can go back through the tree of where it
first appeared and then you'll see it
slide that the Churchillian drift will
occur over time as it gets attributed to
like more more and more famous people
but I think again with that that's
probably again another kind of malignant
side-effect of the 21st century that we
presume that people who are in positions
of authority and in positions of power
are the only ones that can deploy wisdom
you know on that on that note this is
this is a exact quote I know he says
this is Peter Thiel says that uses that
example where they talk about the
whoa is it where it's apparently that
Einstein said compound interest is there
a door the world
yeah a break wonder of the world and
obviously teal goes on that point he
says that actually it probably wasn't
Einstein who said that but he goes to
say that that Einsteins brown we're so
good they're comp is a quite ironic that
it obviously compounds after he died is
that people are still missing buting
quotes to him so it goes to actually
show that compound interest is the 801
but it's rich but on that note though
like there is some weird like contagion
that goes on where I finally I'll have
ideas in my head about ways to behave or
things that are true and when I actually
try and back traced a source I may have
my overheard it on a podcast or I may
all say oh you know the X Y Zed was
created by this person and then I just
won't really think anything of it but he
acted really certain and then I'll catch
myself going oh no it was X Y Zed you
create that you know I have caught
myself like sometimes making points that
go that might not be true actually
and as you sometimes have to call
yourself out because you can easily if
somebody says stuff with enough
confidence you just pass it on and then
before you know it it becomes it becomes
gospel
it's really weird mental fluency is
associated with truthfulness man say
something with enough conviction and
some minority of people will believe if
you want the best example of that is
Frank Abigail and so obviously the
Leonardo DiCaprio did a film on him but
there's a talk at Google Frank Abigail
where he basically tells his whole story
it's actually quite emotional talks
about his lack of dad he's obviously 22
I found out where he works for the FBI
and if you want to talk about AI be a
bit you understand why he was the
greatest con artist ever just because of
how well he he speaks with absolutely no
self-doubt when he tells stories it's
crazy I think he says like her twice
we're in the whole speech it's increase
incredible he just he's just this guy
was pretending to be a pilot at the age
of 16 or whatever right you can see why
about that sorry I always had this
interesting one which is that the the
best calm manner
everybody does that this documentaries
are not here the best comment ever were
realistically there's probably the best
con men can't be in a documentary
because still nobody knows who they're
haha this is weird like survivorship
bias right by the inverse that is
recombinant bias yeah what's next what's
next on the menu where we go so in terms
of what I've got here and this is a bit
of a weird one that I've been thinking
about Weinstein brought it up in the
Rogan podcast about this concepts about
kayfabe which is getting what I'm still
struggling to wrap my head around but
we've seen it more and more and it kind
of goes on to talk about then about it's
weird contagion where professional
wrestling is something that people know
is fake but people kind of still love it
and you've seen it I think you've seen
it at a political level with with Trump
that you seem to have again I don't want
to go down a politics rabbit hole so
literally if I start shopping about
politics one thirty Seconds just jump in
and change the topic you have him for
example where you have some people
obviously out there like diehard
believers but you also have people who
his fans that know he's playing this
weird game and that he's purposely
saying things they almost like from a
market in or a sales perspective and
people almost this kayfabe thing like
almost applies to yourself I find
actually sometimes being irrational is
actually a very rational strategy so
let's say for example this concept of
resistance which comes from like the war
of art book where Stephen Pressfield
says like procrastination is this
external force it's trying to conquer
you and defeat you court has absolute
bollocks but I think interpreting it is
true is actually an effective strategy
and it's probably nothing more if
something's effective you could argue
it's maybe it's irrational but maybe
it's their actual irrational thing to do
and then it gets something done and you
see with professional athletes that how
many professional athletes are atheists
it's quite rare and I think whether
there's a god or the slot of God at war
probably believing that as you about to
go in and octagon and thigh or as you're
about to go on a football pitch for
World Cup final that God is on your side
having that placebo in place is actually
probably very very useful so is that
like a athletes Pascal's wager kind of
in a way like there's benefits there's
benefits of a rush
ality and we've seen it we've seen it
more and more like this blur between you
see it with the the fire fest miss hole
like to fake it to you maybe but
sometimes that becomes I think there's a
negative strain of it which I think we
need to avoid but sometimes it can be
used as a positive side of things of
almost believing something irrationally
but it actually actually works as an
effective measure yeah well I mean
hastily paranoid it highlights it
highlights the fact that we are not
perfectly rational beings and the more
that I read into evolutionary psychology
and this book called blindsight by
Prince Kumaon and Matt Johnson holy [ __ ]
man like I had the guys on there just a
small just a couple of dudes and it just
shows how fallible we are our minds are
completely just a useless the fact that
we don't just get hit by open traffic is
a miracle as far as I'm concerned and
the more that you realize that the more
you realize that an irrational system
trying to be fixed with rational
solutions is probably not always going
to work and that when you add those two
things together you can manipulate the
system into rationality by timesing
irrationality by irrationality as long
as it's the right levels of each right a
quote from shane parish actually which
was put on his FS blog newsletter which
kind of relates to what you're talking
about there tradition is a set of
solutions for which we have forgotten
the problems throw away the solution and
you get the problem back sometimes the
problem is mutated or disappeared often
it is still there as strong as it ever
was that's Donald Kingsbury
that's that's neg it's cool isn't it I
think that kind of relates to a lot of
what Jordan Peterson talks about as well
right you know he talked about these
archetypes and these these kind of meta
themes that have been with us for years
or millennia and
when you read anything that's ancient
but classic Marcus Aurelius meditations
or you know whatever it might be you
realize that the for the problems that
you attribute as side effects of the
21st century are just inbuilt parts of
our nature that everyone's been fighting
with for forever and I'd love I'll
really like that and that's another Rory
Sutherland ISM actually there's one for
bingo for Rory Sutherland which is that
he says the opposite what is it about
the opposite of a good idea and not
always being a the opposite of a bad
idea are also being a bad idea are the
opposite of a I'm gonna butcher this
give me one second I know what you mean
this is rip so sorry bro is me trying to
trying to quote you Rory
so that island of pursuit of an idea
let's see if this comes up the opposite
of a good idea can also be a good idea
that's it don't design for average it
doesn't pay to be logical if everyone
else is being logical the nature or
intention affects the nature of our
experience thanks Rory yep a lot of
because it depends how you define
rationality but even if you look at it
almost as a again but rationality may be
one of those words that has numerous
words within it that we shut about
earlier but some of the the most
rational people I know seem to end up
with the most average or boring results
I wear is because by very definition
they're often like following the crowds
logic and everything that make looks
perfectly logical at the time so going
back to the box container example
earlier um so I think actually being
update weird
again it's a bit of a barbell it can
either go terrifically bad or horrific
aliy right and I think that the the
religion in in professional sports is a
perfect example of that and I think we
need more and more weird people I think
it's very everybody seems to play this
point scoring game now online I mean I
guess it's driven by like getting likes
and getting more and more followers that
by very definition you need people who
go completely
against everything that's currently
there to actually get the desire like if
you look at like going back to the
shipping container the reason why that's
there is because you had a very very
stubborn man who looked like an absolute
idiot to a lot of people and I think
we've seen the death of that Weinstein
talks about this where we have a focus
on excellence now becoming the best at
your craft whereas we don't have that
many rebels of people who actually go
that whole craft is a load of nonsense
we should be doing it this way instead
we should like the guy the table tennis
player I think we talked about this
previously who decided support like foam
on the on the back and as a result he
was like the worst player on the
Japanese team and all of a sudden he was
the best the best of all time or you
have like the foss preflop the the way
now bhai jump is now jumped as a result
of him but he was mocked for a while and
obviously now everybody does it that way
and I think that with social media now
it's a bit harder to be a maverick it's
a bit harder to be a weirdo and I think
we often chasta size people for thinking
differently like even like even worse
whatever criticisms or played praise you
have with him a lot of people the minute
ago might look how erratic and weird he
is they go yeah no [ __ ] I don't think it
takes a imagine him like coming up the
idea of building like a rocket company
it's clearly a weird individual clearly
like doesn't pick up on like social cues
as much as other people otherwise you
don't get that result so I do think a
rationality obviously has its downsides
but a lot of people don't talk about
it's its upsides I love it man I don't
know whether it's just the particular
sliver of the world that I'm exposed to
but I'm not sure how much I agree with
people kind of compromising themselves
down to the lowest common denominator or
popularity being kind of the the first
thing that they search for I see now an
increasingly burgeoning underground
movement of people who are fully
embracing their true nature as long as
it's legal and coming up with ideas
which are contrarian and not being
afraid to put them out online now
obviously this particular
fears within which this can be a little
bit more challenging politics or I guess
right as well law stuff like that but in
terms of worldviews personal development
strategies things like that you know
this there's a million different
iterations and and subcultures of things
that you are like if you wanted to spend
a year in the desert with a piece of
rope and a tarp and a a bottle a couple
of bottles of water there's probably out
there a holiday company that would be
able to do it for you and would keep
supplying you with water or something
like that you know and as the market
starts to reward people who don't just
want to do the status quo I think that
increasingly people will feel more and
more empowered to be themselves and this
is why I know you've got a particular
soft spot for Eric Weinstein I'll let
you riff on that a little bit if you
want to about why you think that he's so
good but having someone like Rogan who
is kind of on the surface a very typical
everyman alpha bro who has this
ridiculous reach him giving someone like
Eric or Lex Friedman
right like there's no way that Lex
should have been on Rogen's pocket he's
been on like five or six times in the
last probably 18 months maybe he's been
on a ton and now Lex has got his own
ridiculously big podcast and he's
getting cool people on it all this
saucer and you're like what you know Lex
is definitely on the spectrum I
absolutely adore him Lex if you're
listening I'd love you to reply to my
email but he's great but like why him
you know and then you have someone who
permits these subcultures to to rise to
the surface and the more that you have
role models like that if people who are
unapologetically just doing them you
know like just do your thing sister like
you get more that you've got those
people doing that I think it sets a
fantastic example for people moving
forward the yeah I completely agree I
think that's one of the things that
Rogen has done very well in the comedy
space but wider that he is the moist
probably
positive some man on the planet he's
maybe a matter people Oh careers to him
elect incredibly tiny peopie and I said
he's done a lot of good for the world
and that he's constantly bringing people
up but it's not this negative sum game
because I think he quickly realized that
attention is is everywhere and there's
seven billion people on the planet so
providing more and more positive so my
things better a slightly nuanced note
though is that and even you may have
this to some extent that you may try and
be like the like the most become the
most enlightened version of yourself but
when you're under the name Chris
Williamson and you have you still have
your identity to protect you still
always play in a bit of a at least I I
know I have to that you only plan is bit
of a weird ego game that you still have
an identity protect to protect and often
the the best going back to like either
end of the spectrum the best accounts on
the internet I'd say and the worst
accounts on the internet are often
anonymous because they're then free to
do things about their identity and you
have a look let's say you look at
Satoshi Nakamoto like if the person who
created Bitcoin was known like he would
even be a god knows what would happen at
this apparently imagines a purpose
reason why he or she did that and I
think it works out quite well we say
we've got Jed McKenna the writer I think
there's something about anonymity at
times that people want to vanish from
social medias because the trolling that
goes on but I actually think it's an
incredibly important thing in protecting
people's identity and you can then be a
bit weirder and I think this is I would
be surprised if there's actually a lot
of anonymous accounts out there of
people who are very famous and well
known and they actually have sub
anonymous accounts as well so we're
dividing with three different ideas in a
sandbox areas life going back to that
eric has this weird thing where when
he's doing he's like 18 are Mac sessions
trying to figure out the geometric
patterns of the universe he talks about
it of what's the what's the condition
where you can just sometimes say the
wrong words and swear a lot
Janina me to rat around correct yeah so
he calls it like voluntary Tourette's
so you'll sit by a room in himself and
he'll just think everybody's this is my
it's great
everything in there except you'll just
say the word not allowed to say out loud
before he starts working and he's there
for like in the mindset of like just
fully thinking different to everybody
else
um yes accent I love it man um what else
what else we got on the odd you want to
do an out join to join a riff on Eric
for a bit or Joanna and Johnny go into
some else no I think I think what are
the points for to go back to I just have
it written down or strand to you is that
when we went back to the leverage thing
as well one of the points I didn't make
at the end which is what Steve Jobs says
which is we go back to the whole bicycle
the humor on the bicycle being the most
effective thing which is that the
internet or the computer he says the
computer at the time is the bicycle of
the mind and I think that's one of the
most beautiful ways of understanding
like leverage of modern leverage and I
think that the yeah there's a lot of
with everything that's going on there's
gonna be so many careers that come out
of the internet them just absolutely
like fascinated by the space it's
beautiful to say yeah I agree man I
think um
it's gonna be interesting to see what
happens after this you know like it's
all well and good having a global
pandemic in a society that's in the
early 1900s that can adapt a little bit
of change but not tons and certainly not
globally but when you have a site which
is able to move as quickly as ours is
now and has technology can do leverage
can have instant communication you know
all that sort of stuff
the the pace of change when change is
forced upon it kind of almost bounces
back twice as hard you know I mean it's
like throwing the tennis ball at the
wall and then the wall moving towards
you like a tennis racket and whacking
you back in the face with it so I think
that'll be really interesting tell you
one thing so this is only gonna be
probably for British people this is just
something - not even a mental model but
something I was thinking about the other
day while I was in the ouster as self
service thing and I've seen tons of
people complain right about how annoying
that as their self-service narrator lady
is so you can imagine if you're American
me listening to this you're in Costco or
wherever it might be like Target or
something and you're going through one
of the self-service checkout and in Asda
you're gonna have to imagine this so
you're scanning your stuff and the
lady's voice that says thanks that scan
now put it in the basket at the bagging
area is so quick and it does not stop
right so you scale like Boop Thanks
that's got me like [ __ ] that I don't
hear any thinking this is every single
time you might have 40 items in your
basket for those of us that are air pod
pros aficionados it kind of doesn't
really matter so much turn that turn
that noise cancelling on boy it's super
night and what I realized was actually
that because you can cut it off if
you're super quick so that could be
programmed in to ensure that people scan
the stuff put it in the bagging area as
quickly as possible because they don't
want to hear that lady's voice I like a
stir you smart you've got two things
you've got all right second third all
the consequences that come of like bugs
and stuff like that and you have like
the psychological versus the logical
we're one of my favorite Rory Sutherland
things which I guess we briefly
mentioned earlier but how things are you
have the like engineering efficiency of
like logic of one plus one equals two
but then you have this weird
psychological irrational world that
human beings operate under I'm not sure
if it's still true but when the whole
corona thing happened they were reports
they're like the corona beer sales like
de la mitad look the worth the worth I
think it's like a hundred million that
they've gone down by and Americans were
surveyed and over a third of Americans
said that they would not buy a Corona
beer for fear of infection but this is
one of the things that is purely
psychological that you can see like
psycho logic that even though I think
the people who would say they wouldn't
drink Corona anymore because you I
reckon you've got two forms of consumers
you've got one too like consciously I
almost idiot two out yeah one trick
Corona and then you've actually got a
lot of people who for whatever reason
they just may be less likely to buy it
they're gonna get us all I'm gonna force
a fancier Modelo no exactly dela virus
out there ever but it's weird but that's
a that's a thing isn't it and that like
you've seen that there where there's
clearly no logic behind it but in our
heads there is a form of logic I think
that a rational community will often I
just dismiss that a stupidity and idiocy
but I think it's supposed to show a lot
about the way we think and the way we
operate what's really bizarre what also
naturally risk-averse creatures right
and rightly so when you see or when you
learn the x zero mental model that we
dropped earlier on like it makes sense
it makes sense to have an existential
fear of walking out of your door it
makes sense to double-check that that
condom doesn't have a hole in it it
makes sense to make sure that you're
wearing your seat belt
you know like of course it does and that
again it links into the quote from Shane
parish tradition is a set of solutions
for which we have forgotten the problems
throw away the solution and you get the
problem back like that's why you have
these things over time and I spent my
birthday this year in Athens so I spent
it cycling around Athens
the stoic lay which is where Zeno
obsidium created stoicism so stoicism
stoah is like a sort of building veranda
type thing and it's the stoah the stoic
Palais is where stoicism was created so
I'm walking through the gardens where
Seneca and Plato would have walked right
and and zeno obsidian which is like
modern-day Cyprus would have done as
well and I'm walking through there and
I'm looking around and we went on this
amazing tour anyone that goes to Athens
the mythology tour is fantastic and um
you're looking at these ancient stores
and buildings and you go see the
Acropolis right and you go up and is the
temple of nike and the Parthenon and all
that sort of stuff and um you're looking
at the stories that are displayed in
these huge sculptures and all the
different all the different elements
that parts of these stories and you
realize you like hang on so much of what
they're talking about here are universal
universally applicable laws the things
which then maybe they were symbolic
perhaps there was something that was
only believed in a very narrative sense
everything was personified right because
it was stories there wasn't certified
fact-checking you know there was no
what's that fact-checking website for
when people have rumors not Wikipedia
the other one I know I know
Snopes snobs yes no there's no there's
no like ancient Snopes or whatever just
a bunch of stone tablets that you can go
through but I was just walking through
and it really really made me appreciate
standing on the top of the Acropolis
looking out over earth and seeing all of
this of beauty and wisdom but
symbolically and I think in like a hyper
rational society what happens is that we
discard the wisdom of the past like
there's been people around for a lot
longer than you and I know that this
value in science and I know that this
value in a logical and reduction like
reductionist reasoning but there's been
a lot of Minds working at this for a
long time I also think that you've
mentioned then that you discard the
wisdom of the past I always do think
when you're so consensus focused
or so Talib uses that example of the
absence of evidence isn't evidence of
absence and you realize this like people
like quote like there's no study for
that bro there's no study for that and
you've seen like with all the health
crisis going on my how this thing's
constantly changing then people were
saying things three months ago and now
wrong and now now that's wrong when it's
constantly changing but I think to go
back to the momentum model store not
only do you discard the wisdom of the
past you also discard and probably even
more importantly or at least equally or
significantly importantly the the wisdom
and the value of the future of future
trends as well because I think that
let's say if in 2009 somebody was
talking to you about crypto currencies
you got what you wanted like it was just
so against the consensus and if you have
such a closed mind of where there's been
studies so far or where goldman sachs
are putting their money you're like
you're just always gonna get average
results because you're following the
crowd and don't get me wrong it may
actually be a safe investment strategy
and you may just get normal you know I
mean you never go to zero so Alisha at
least you might be safe but you you
rarely ever get to see like specific
knowledge like the intricacies of like
frontiers and a nuance and that's why I
love hanging around with like curious
people because you'll find that you will
tell you like the weirdest new thing
that's happening so that an example this
would be let's say you got into like
Facebook marketing in 2010 when he was
like seen as this like fad like why you
why would anybody advertise next what
farm bill thing and a photo of like
somebody's relationship status that was
such a weird thing but if you would've
been on that frontier and been that
weirdo that you had so much future value
and I think particularly for young
people that there's so much value on
being on the edge of frontiers as
opposed to going and as you've seen now
everything that's happened like actually
a job at Deloitte or a big consultancy
firm might not be the most like the
safest option actually it might the the
the riskier option is often in taking
like no risks and I think the edge of
the edge of specific knowledge is
fascinating and I think that we have to
be a bit weird for a set I absolutely
love that I think as well like we keep
on harping on about it and we did on the
first one and I created an entire video
off the back of a quote about you what
you sent me on thinking about weird
people and the way that we are and stuff
like that but I really do hope that some
of the things that we talk about do kind
of give people the license to embrace
their own uniqueness and their own
individuality and again like this isn't
for either of us to say like both of us
know that were just fallible shaven
chimps right and that we're totally like
not not even slightly actualized we
ain't got a clue what's going on but one
of the things that I do know is true in
this life is that your unique offering
to this world is your power like there
is no one else
by definition who has your life
experiences and your genetic makeup and
has inhabited all of the different space
that particular spatial coordinates that
you have it's impossible it hasn't
happened
therefore by synthesizing all of those
things by synthesizing the way you were
brought up and your traumas and your
predispositions and your fears and your
joys new successes and everything by
adding that together that is your
competitive advantage that is how you
move the needle in the world and in your
own life so on that like one of the my
going back to leverage a little bit is
like the mental model of almost like a
judo throw like using some things own
momentum
against itself and therefore you apply a
lot less force and the biggest thing and
said the I struggled with and I think
most people do with hey you don't want
to be out of the crowd you don't want
people to think you're weird you don't
want people to think you're a loser it's
just so socially conditioned I'm
probably biologically programmed but
almost to flip that on its head and go
to yourself I almost have a razor in
place which is if people don't think
you're weird if people don't aren't like
snidely laughing about you a little bit
at your probably almost definitely not
taking enough risks and that's fine if
you just what if you just want to if you
just want to fit in that's fine but you
almost have to reframe that to yourself
to try and judo throw that social
condition in that biological programming
and go if that's not happening I'm by
their very definition I'm just fitting
in with the crowd I'm not taking any
risks at all so that McGill's razor
number two
the wheat that we and this raised
amazing releases oh look at that mic
drop I love it so there's this quote
from atomic habits that James clears got
I always come back to changing your
habits often requires you to change your
tribe each tribe has a set of shared
expectations behaviors that conform to
the shared expectations are attractive
behaviors that conflict with the shared
expectations are unattractive it's hard
to go against the group often changing
your behaviour requires you to change
your tribe so a lot of the time then I'm
a big sobriety advocate right and this
is one of the things that I actually use
it to raise it technically that I used
to work out whether your friends want
the best for you whether you should stay
friends with them it's like if when you
start to enact behavior change and grow
your friends don't support you instead
they get triggered by the fact that
their own shortcomings are being
identified by your growth you are in a
the wrong group of friends like if the
opportunity for you to do a podcast the
first thing that I think is [ __ ] I want
to listen to that I want to subscribe to
that I want to help you we've been
talking about how to do your audio about
what mic you need to buy about what
webcam you need to know this sort of
stuff right like I want that for you
because I don't feel threatened by your
growth I feel like if you were to grow
that it would not only grow me but I
just want the best for you right there's
a lot of people out there who are
friends that don't want the best for
them yeah it's true sometimes it's not
even what the best for them but their
conditioning may be so different
I could see great tweets of like if you
post oh I've just started my masters or
I just started another degree like or
I've just I've just graduated which I
think I I swear at who doesn't graduate
unless you drop out why how do you fail
like a modern non stem degree is insane
like it's what it's harder to fail than
it is to but it is if you post that on I
don't mean to bike like be too rude or
anything but if you post that on there
with your certificate like everybody
it's hundreds of likes and it's like
this every graduation day there's this
big thing about it but realistically
when you break it down to first
principles
ended a horrific amount of debt to get a
piece of paper which I don't think is as
meaningless as like the full college
ante college or university people make
out because there's definitely that
social value etc etc that I think online
courses have not been able to do yet but
if you then contrast that with when
friends like so I've just launched this
new business and it gets like for like
some people will even like you when
people invite them to like the Facebook
page people you can see the page and not
like it like it's really weird but I
think that's because it's way easy and
outside the box to try and start
something like that as opposed to hey
I've got this degree we've all got
degrees that we like this therefore
we're all in this same matrix together
and it all makes sense because if if
you've got it I've got it
it's all working and let's ignore the
debt yeah it's so it's almost like
what's that thing when when comedians
aren't that funny but they get the
audience claps because they agree so
they don't they say something that's
like it you've got like a super sort of
lefty crowd or whatever and you say
something to criticize this Trump or
you've got like a super rightly crowd me
so some of the criticize is like Bernie
or whatever and it's not actually that
funny but it's just like yeah yeah kind
of playing like that and you're right
it's like the same thing I had this
tweet the other a couple of months ago
that hit the nail on the head about that
man like people need to guess their
friends are more like they have to do it
and there's no other alternative word
for it gassing your friends up is
exactly what the term should be
regardless of how colloquial or
particularly you want to be about it if
your buddies start up a business like
support them it's [ __ ] mud how many
people will share a new Rihanna ex humor
collaboration video like oh my god yes
Queen and you like this bro your buddy
just opened a coffee shop that's a mile
away from your house and you've never
been like well I said what are you doing
I think two notes though to judo throw
that against itself is to Alma because
you is to then say it but the person who
that say for example you you do instant
yourself and then they're sharing
Rihanna's new underwear underwear range
right which I didn't Freudian slip there
judge I did share my cell phone but
first Judah pray against itself
I imagine this is how at least try and
think whether it's I can actually put it
in practice his dear friend of okay it's
a good filter of actually who your
friends are so it's almost a positive
thing in a sense but I think I just
think it so much of it comes down to
yeah what's what's expected and what
isn't expected and the the conditioning
condition that goes on and it's it's
really yeah really bizarre yeah man look
George we made it my mental models 103
have you got anything else that you need
to get off your chest before we finish
no I think I think that's that's pretty
much it I just yeah and I guess the
biggest takeaway is if you can be a bit
weirdo and you can have people laugh at
you more and I think I say this a lie
because it then tries to encourage me to
do it a bit too I think that the world
would be a bit of a better place this
probably it really is cliche as that
sounds no man I absolutely agree so
what's your twitter now it keeps
changing no it's George Mac George
underscore underscore Mac George
underscore underscore Mac you need to go
and follow him
you're gonna be tweeting I'm sure over
the next few weeks as as more
interesting stuff comes in oh it's
enough enough regulation in you in your
tweeting recently you're tiny a little
bit more Horan seeing you more time to
think yeah so yeah thank you so much man
you know this I absolutely do adore
having you on and it makes me feel very
gratified that you're number one you
know he got all of these guys there's no
reason apart from the bot farm but there
is no reason that you should be number
one you know like there's no real up
against like the biggest guys on the
planet Douglas Murray it Robert Greene
five times New York Times bestselling
author and then just sat at the top is
just some guy from the middle of the UK
it's George underscore underscore mark
on Twitter that's how it is ladies and
gentlemen look man thank you so much I'm
sure that we will be back with mental
models 104 the link to George's Twitter
and anything else that we find it's
interesting will be linked in the show
notes below
George man thank you stay with that
Chris thank you for having me
[Music]
you